> LINES OPE
HEAD OF ARCERAL LOHIND N
STORE Y MUSEUM I SE
MAOUATBAN
HENEF NCNGRSD GONOT ADELAN
NDEC ILYMOE,SAICE IDTO DS H HE
NCRIRTD YINSICEB  Y
ANMAE TE
IKEROKY  T
HNDALY  T
RSRS WESVOERREEDSTYOES OLIT W WM
ROMUOUVEESTH BINWHN
ZEEXTHTORSNE
HEAN IA
IQHON
IO OOUERMOON
STLIEY FARU' T QU
GO
TH'RE
ASEN, ,
E ESARE ESCUSS FIDNTW NNCE OE  E
LICTH
WOA  TARS N ESLOCK EATBEE T S HG
UEAMCE X
AR FILOSOTF  TH ESE , OU ISOONRI
P XCD
ADE I W
IO, E HS SIPAHOE >>TH O HS ME A
ICOURE AN WT  ES NGSHONMEANPHRE
STSE HTOSAETEYF
LEINTLANT HAISD BONDDET NTIMPENI
YPS
TEY A E BUD O
FEPS SNTUT MORG  HTO EGRROASBUPO
RI
WIOUMPSAWITHY EV WROEEVETIRTD OD
OE OANEX
ITITICHOTOLABNGO MEEMHENCY ECEH